comment la france aurait-elle pu peser
de tout son poids sur les grandes
décisions internationales alors qu'en
douze ans 24 gouvernements se sont
succédé à sa tête avec une moyenne
d'existence de six mois à peine durant
la même période
l'angleterre a connu quatre gouvernement
représentant 2 politique
[Musique]
les etats-unis n'ont eu que deux
l'allemagne a le même gouvernement
depuis dix ans en france l'instabilité
est née d'une constitution une opinion
trop divisée n'a jamais réussi à amender
malgré 99 proposition de révision en 12
ans opinion de georges bidault le 10
juin 55 la nécessité d'une révision
n'est plus contestée edgar faure le 17
janvier 52 cette réforme conditionne
l'avenir de nos institutions
mendès-france le 3 juin 53
je demanderai au parlement d'examiner
très prochainement la réforme
constitutionnelle
guy mollet le 31 janvier 56 le premier
problème est celui de la réforme de nos
institutions
antoine pinay le 6 mars 50,2 une réforme
de la constitution est nécessaire
christian pineau le 8 février 55
souligne la volonté du gouvernement de
s'attacher à la restauration de
l'autorité de l'état
pierre pfimlin a dit je sais par
expérience que nos institutions
fonctionnent mal je sais que de grands
changements sont nécessaires
paul reynaud a dit il faut réviser la
constitution
la stabilité de nos gouvernements
appliquent nos amis dans le monde et
fait la richesse de nos ennemis
[Musique]
n'ayant pu réviser la constitution le
parlement a confié ce soir au
gouvernement en le chargeant de
soumettre au peuple le texte de la
nouvelle constitution par la voie du
référendum
cette procédure utilisée par robespierre
pour la première fois en france a été
adopté par de nombreux pays occidentaux
tels que la belgique et l'italie
[Musique]
et
pour sa part la suisse dont on cite
volontiers en exemple l'esprit
démocratique réutiliser 48 fois le
référendum en moins d'un siècle
la france est aujourd'hui parvenu à l'un
de ces rendez-vous que fixe
périodiquement l'histoire dans la vie
des nations qui refuse de mourir à ce
rendez vous ne soyez pas absents
[Musique]
pensée française soyez volontaire de
votre combat chacun de vous détient par
sa voix une parcelle de cette
responsabilité collective qui justifie
seul l'orgueil de votre liberté français
et françaises
soyez responsable de votre liberté mais
c'est aussi de l'avenir de vos enfants
que votre choix sera l'exacte monnaie un
jour il vous en sera demandé qu'on
français et françaises par votre voix
s'accomplira le destin de vos fils
[Musique]